[Music]
it's been nearly 7even years since the
last movie in the Alien series called
alien Covenant even though Prometheus
and Covenant were met with mixed
reactions from viewers the franchise is
far from over a new installment of the
sci-fi classic is already in the works
in fact we can expect both a new movie
and a first Alien series of course many
people are wondering how exactly the
long running cult franchise will
continue we have compiled all the latest
information for you in this video This
Way you can get your own idea of what to
expect from the new alien releases we
talk about the upcoming movie the new
series and a mysterious already
completed spin-off that Disney is
keeping under wraps for unknown reasons
against the will of the creators enjoy
our new
original the new alien movie Bears the
working title Romulus it is not yet
known what it will actually be named in
the end filming has already been
concluded and the movie is currently in
post- production therefore we already
have all kinds of information about the
plot the cast and what is happening
behind the
scenes alien Romulus will have a
standalone story that works
independently of the previous movies
this means that it does not tie in with
the plot of Prometheus Covenant or the
original movies the creators claim that
they intend to provide access to the
franchise for more people than just
DieHard fans they also want to give
newcomers the opportunity to enter the
world of alien the new movie will be set
right between the first and second part
it is therefore highly doubtful that we
will get to see Sigourney Weaver as
Ellen RI
as she ends up flying through space in a
sleep pod incidentally District 9
director Neil Blan Camp already had the
idea of setting another movie between
alien and Aliens but sadly the long
discussed alien film by the science
fiction veteran never happened the plot
of Romulus revolves around a group of
young men and women on a remote Outpost
they come into contact with the famous
face huggers beings that place eggs in
humans to create the dreaded Xenomorphs
it is still unknown whether the story
will be limited to one location and
whether there'll be just one movie or
further
sequels the cast of alien Romulus has
been significantly rejuvenated in
comparison to the older films Kaylee
spany a 25-year-old American who
appeared in Pacific Rim Uprising and
other Productions is taking on the lead
role she is currently playing the
starring role of Elvis's wife in
Priscilla at her side we will see
Isabella Merced not only has she
previously played the leading role in
Dora in the lost city of gold she will
also play an important character in the
upcoming Madam web Archie Reno Maybe
familiar to some from the Netflix series
Shadow and Bone David Johnson meanwhile
was previously cast in the romcom Ry
Lane other actors such as Spike Fern and
Eileen woo are rather less well-known a
somewhat more prominent name has been
rumored for a long time but is yet to be
officially confirmed Phoebe Waller
Bridge known for example from her hit
series flea bag and Indiana Jones in the
dial of Destiny It is believed that she
could be playing an Android Waller
Bridge has been heard at least once
before in a similar role namely in Solo
a Star Wars Story the focus on a younger
cast is a new approach for the Alien
series and will probably not be met with
approval from viewers but although this
decision looks like it is aimed at a
younger mainstream audience the makers
describe it more as a dark and
claustrophobic horror movie Alien
Romulus is being produced by Ridley
Scott who already directed the first
part and also worked as a producer on
Prometheus and Covenant a new facee in
the alien franchise is taking on the
director's role however to give the
movie That Special Touch of shock and
horror the director of the Evil Dead
reboot fed Alvarez has been hired he
also wrote the screenplay together with
his colleague Roto sagz with this crew
there is good reason to hope that the
movie will not be too softened a first
impression is provided by a Set photo in
which we can see a puppet of the dreaded
face hugger fie Alvarez wants to do
things properly with his alien movie and
above all impress past Master Ridley
Scott he should get to see the work
before anyone else as Alvarez revealed
at the DGA Latino Summit 2023 in
conversation with horror icon gear Del
Toro the director talked about Scott's
strict standards especially when it
comes to his own movies despite initial
concerns however Alvarez received
surprisingly positive feedback not only
did Scott praise the movie as bloody
great he also emphasized the excellent
dialogue apparently Scott spent an hour
talking to Alvarez about the movie and
expressed his admiration of course this
gives us hope for a more than decent new
addition to the series of alien movies
alien Romulus is due to be released on
August 16th 2024 so we probably won't
have to wait much longer for a first
teaser
trailer in addition to the new alien
movie another spin-off is in the works
it comes from the creator of the
successful Fargo series Noah Holly this
will be the first time the Eerie
Creature from the alien world has ever
been featured in a series and he already
has very specific ideas for this
project his theory in a 2-hour movie The
Plot can be structured in such a way
that the only question is whether the
protagonist Will Survive but that
doesn't work with the series even if you
make the best action horror for 60% of
the time there is still 40% where
something else has to happen so the
series creator has come up with
something new for the franchise unlike
in the movies the alien will not be up
to Mischief on a spaceship or an alien
planet instead it will be Unleashed on
Earth Holly is thus breaking with the
tradition of the protagonist being more
or less trapped in one place with the
alien it will surely be interesting to
see what earth looks like in the alien
franchise and how it responds to the
xenomorph in the leading role of the
Alien series we will see Sydney Chandler
the 27-year-old American has only had
minor roles so far so this could be her
big breakthrough in the series she plays
Wendy a metahuman who has the body of an
adult and the mind of a child according
to the latest reports her Mentor will be
played by none other than Timothy olant
who will play an Android called kersch
in addition to his leading role in the
video game adaptation Hitman olant is
best known as a popular series actor
such as in Justified Deadwood and the
Book of Boba Fett is also appeared in
Noah Holly's Fargo series Alex lur is
also not entirely unknown most of you
will know him from the Netflix series
the end of the [__] world in Andor
although he doesn't look particularly
threatening normally he's supposed to
play a soldier called CJ Samuel blankin
is joining the cast as well he recently
had a part in the series the Continental
from the world of John Wick now he is to
play a CEO called Bob Cavalier
metahumans and roids soldiers and CEOs
the characters certainly sound
characteristic of the franchise the cast
already includes numerous other names
however little is known about their
roles the idea for an Alien series
emerged back in 2019 at the time it was
said that both a liveaction and an
animated series would be produced the
liveaction version was given the green
light in December 2020 in the end it
took 2 and 1/2 years for the series to
go into pre-production filming began in
July 2023 albeit without lead actress
Sydney Chandler because of the Hollywood
strikes filming is now set to resume in
January 2024 and is expected to run
until July however the series is not
expected to be released before 2025 so
it will presumably be quite a while
before we see the first
images in addition to the two high
potential projects we don't want to
leave another spin-off entirely
unmentioned even if its fate looks
anything but promising we're talking
about the fully completed Alien versus
Predator Animated Series this was
originally commissioned by 20th Century
Fox Disney acquired the distributor in
2019 and seems to have no interest in
releasing the finished series much to
the displeasure of producer Joshua ISO
in the early summer of 2023 the creaters
therefore announced their plan to
release the animated series on DVD
independently of TV and streaming
services since then things have gone
quiet about the alien spin-off which is
still waiting to see the light of
day well that's all the latest
information on the new alien projects
what do you think of the idea of
unleashing the alien on Earth and what
is your favorite movie in the franchise
and why let us know in the comments and
like this video If you enjoyed our
little
[Music]
update